look out Sony Hawkeye is taking aim it's
you and he never misses on August 20th
Hollywood was rocked when reports
surfaced that Sony and Disney couldn't
come to terms on a new agreement to keep
Tom Hollands spider-man in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Thank You mr. star
I'm good you're good good how are you
good unless the circumstances change
dramatically
it looks like the 23 year old Holland is
done showing up in the MCU movies after
five appearances over the past three
years beginning with 2016 s Captain
America Civil War and ending with 2019
spider-man far from home the vast
majority of people involved including
Marvel Studios head Kevin Feige and
Holland himself have kept quiet so far
on the bombshell news but one of the
Avengers has spoken out Jeremy Renner
has played Clint Barton also known as
Hawkeye in the MCU for eight years since
first appearing in 2011's Thor took to
Instagram on August 21st to vent his
feelings on the controversial subject he
uploaded a still of himself an Avengers
end game with a caption that reads hey
Sony Pictures we want spider-man back to
the real Stan Lee and Marvel please
thank you Congrats
spider-man rocks hashtag bow and arrow
emoji please poor grammar and odd
hashtagging aside it's clear that Renner
is clamoring for a new Spidey deal and
that he falls on the Disney side of the
dividing line Renner has many irons in
the fire including starring in major
Hollywood films launching a musical
career and appearing in some slightly
strange Jeep commercials but it's
obvious that Disney and Marvel offered
the actor his steadiest gig the man
knows how hard it can be to find work in
Hollywood having been a makeup artist
early in his career to make ends meet at
a time where he couldn't find casting
anywhere thankfully Renner's place in
the MCU is locked tight as he slated to
star on the upcoming Marvel series
Hawkeye set for release on the disney +
streaming service sometime in the future
some say it's smart of Renner to not
look a gift horse in the mouth and
instead come to Disney's defense after
Sony has put the blame on the house of
mouse but it's also possible that he
just really likes the new spider-man
movies and doesn't want to deal with a
disaster like the amazed
spider-man 2 again about that
spider guy Tibet he's disappeared seems
like everybody really needs him after
the events of Avengers endgame and
spider-man far from home the webslinger
seemed poised to take on a central role
in the MCU by continuing Tony Stark's
legacy and keeping the memory of his
late mentor alive unfortunately placing
Peter Parker at the center of the MCU
may have been a misstep on the part of
Marvel's Feige as it arguably puts
Disney at a distinct disadvantage in
negotiations with Sony with Sony having
the sole film rights to spider-man
rights the company has held since 1999
when Marvel was holding a licensing fire
sale to stave off bankruptcy Disney was
already on the wrong side of the
corporate power struggle setting
spider-man up to become an Avenger and a
key cog in the future of the franchise
may have only made matters worse now
they've set up a story that may well be
unfinished depending on how things shake
out hopefully Renner's plea for help is
the first of many public comments by
Marvel related figures on the Marvel
Sony split after all this is the social
media age where everyone and their
mother lets loose their every thought
online the major players have been
decidedly quiet on the subject thus far
though fans are surely waiting with
bated breath to hear what Tom Holland
himself has to say it would also be very
interesting to hear what Marvel head
honcho Feige has to say after having
spider-man ripped from his future MCU
plans after writing the ship for Sony in
the first place for now Marvel lights
will have to be happy with Hawkeye
taking his aim and shooting his shot
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
the MCU are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
you